all right thanks thanks everyone for
having us so my name is Brad Rhodes eski
I'm a founder of a start-up that's
called drone i/o we do continuous
integration deployment and DevOps tools
were located here in the Bay Area really
excited to be here especially knowing
the background with Google web toolkit
we were huge quit programmers over the
last year's I think I still have like an
html5 Nintendo emulator out on the App
Store somewhere so go check it out but
don't you play with any illegal games or
anything like that so hi I'm Matt Norris
I'm actually a program manager at
General Electric I do software
development and architecture and
basically my department devils and lots
of new technologies brings new
technologies into my business and I have
a background in graphics and animation
and I'm also very very excited to be
here
it's almost as excited as this guy I
don't know if I'm as excited because I
can't jump that high in the air but but
as said dart 1.0 is out so that's great
it means you've got a stable library to
play with and we're gonna actually you
know show you the benefits right now so
Brad is going to go into a demo of a
very simple application that will go
through soup to nuts yeah thanks I'd say
and so I think one of the interesting
things to just add on about a dart 1.0
right
the language is stable the API stable
they're working on performance these are
all great things but a language is more
than just the syntax you know as Seth
said it's an ecosystem so if you're
gonna be developing in dart you want to
know what technologies are available
what tools what frameworks and so these
are the things we're gonna go to and to
do that we wanted to like like max had
build an app soup-to-nuts
and go through the code client server
database and so I'm just gonna click on
this so we'll jump out and prepare to be
amazed by an awesome URL shortener so
well pretty much just works as you would
expect if you I'm going to type in a URL
and I'm gonna click shorten and it's
gonna shorten it and then I'm gonna
click it and you know it it goes and of
course the ironic thing is the shortened
URL was actually I think longer than
google.com but that's you know yeah not
a big deal if that's the worst thing
that happens the demo then I think we're
doing ok yeah and so you know just to
describe how that we did a client-side
app in dart we did the server-side code
in dart and we're actually persisting
hashing the URLs and persisting those in
a Redis key value store so that when you
visit the URL it's pulling the hash out
and sending you to the link all right so
let's jump back in and I kind of already
talked about that what we'll learn but
client server-side app we're going to
talk about testing we're going to talk
about a little bit about deploying sub
language features some tools a lot of
people here from a Java background so I
know you'll care about the tools things
like continuous integration etc
so there's a couple of things you'll
notice that in on the client we're going
to start there and there's actually the
way that you include dart into your web
application is very similar to you know
it's very familiar as to how you include
JavaScript so there's a script include
you see the type is actually application
dart and what allows us to to use this
in a in a browser that's outside of
dartium which seth went over in terms of
development is dart j/s so that's what
takes your dart code compiles it into
JSO --that it can be used in any browser
the to dive into the index itself each
dart application really starts off as
two key files we've got the HTML file
and then we've got your your dart script
that's running and in our particular
form there's the input where you put
your long URL we've got a button that
you click so that you know it actually
calls dart from the background that's
where we have you know the action wired
up and we've got a hidden anchor tag
which that's where we're going to stuff
the hashed short URL when we're all said
and done darts a little bit different
than javascript if you'll notice each
dart file actually has a main which you
know it's not a huge surprise if you've
come from you know Java or any other
language it's just the way that the
convention that's used and in just in
this particular instance the only thing
we're really doing here is we're wiring
up the listener to the button itself on
the HTML file and really kind of a cool
thing though is the simplicity in which
you can do this if you're familiar with
jQuery it's you'll feel right at home
dart uses a query selector so that
you're able to actually you know grab
what you need to and attach the event
listener that way
all right so we've wired up the on-click
this is just a quick look at the the
onclick function again if you've coded
in JavaScript this should look extremely
familiar we're creating the HTTP request
we have the onreadystatechange so when
we send the request we can get a
response back of course there's some
more complete code this demo is posted
we just didn't stuff it all into these
slides and then when we get the response
back we're gonna use that to populate
the form calling this show text method
method and then there's one thing I
wanted to cover because you guys are
going through dart you're gonna see some
new syntax things and some people had
some questions like what's what's going
on with this thing right here this
underscore and really it's just the
listener is invoking this function on
callback in it would typically be
passing in event handler data and we're
just gonna ignore it and so that's what
we're doing with that underscores we
just only care about it and so you'll
see that from time to time in dart code
and maybe even further in this demo and
so as we see these types of things we'll
try to point out what they mean
so Seth mentioned this as well this is
one of the really cool things that we
found about dart was the syntactic sugar
it takes a lot of the you know
boilerplate stuff that you're used to
kind of putting together and having to
piece together in other languages and
and boils it down so that you're not you
know you're not using as much you're not
thinking through as much and string
interpolation is is a great example of
this the thing that I found actually
most you know fascinating was the
Cascades so Seth also covered that I'm
gonna gush a little bit more about this
because it's this is where you know as
as developers you're gonna spend you
know 90 percent of your time is spent
maintaining stuff not writing it and
anything that you write is inherently
shared with other people you work on
teams and even yourself right you know a
few months later after you write
something and go back to it you might
not quite remember exactly what it did
so this is you know anything that you
can do with a language to make it more
readable make it more like prose it's a
great thing
you know programming is poetry you're
all writers and this is this makes your
job easier it's it's absolutely
fantastic and it really helps in
maintaining things you know in the
future so for this particular just to
explain what's going on in the code the
the URL short is you know the the at the
anchor tag that we're actually going to
update the attributes when the show text
function is is invoked and just like in
the code that you saw before we're
taking all of the things that we want to
change about it we want to put the new
you know href in there we want to change
its name so that you see what the actual
short hashed link is and we're doing it
with Cascades so it's very very easy to
read and maintain later alright so now
what I'd like to do is just jump back to
the demo who would have thought we can
actually demo more with this
let's go we're gonna go to yahoo.com and
we generated the hash and boom we didn't
redirect so what happened what broke
and so let's jump back into the pitch
and you know we can kind of further
analyze what happened here well we
didn't type the HTTP we just typed the
www and it turns out when the server
tried to do the redirect without the
HTTP it wasn't able to do so and those
are kind of like the mundane details
that is developers sometimes we forget
about and so we thought that was a nice
segue in to the next topic which is
gonna be unit tests so every time you
kind of come across one of these things
that might not crop you know cross your
mind earlier when you develop something
every time you know somebody finds a bug
you want to write that unit test so that
you make sure you have coverage going
forward this is starting from the client
side we're going to take a look at how
you know to implement this in dart the
first thing you do is import the unit
test library which is you know it's
baked into it's thought of from the very
first you know implementation baked into
dart itself so it's really great you
also will pull in a HTML enhanced
configuration which this will show you
what the output is in a second but
basically when you're doing your
development workflow in dartium it's a
it's a simple command to actually format
the results of the unit test and in a
nice way in the browser and finally the
the meat of this is the test itself so
you know what we said when you know
somebody came in with a bug report and
said hey I tried to put in this URL and
it it didn't work you say ok it's
because we forgot the protocol we now
write a couple of tests to make sure
that we have that coverage going forward
we check that it's a you know is valid
URL is working and that we get
everything you know stuff the protocol
and if people do not include that and so
when you run the the test itself this is
the output that you get it shows you
that you know all your tests have passed
you're green so you're good to go
actually one more thing that I wanted to
just bring up cuz wit came up earlier
and we've got a lot of Java developers I
remember
one thing I love about this is that I
can run my tests directly against a real
Dom if you're programming equip before
maybe you remember like ray Ryan's talk
on model-view-presenter
and you had to actually mock your entire
UI and so I think this is awesome that
when I write my unit tests against my
web page I could hit an actual real DOM
and I don't have to you know write all
that extra boilerplate mocking code so
so like Brad said you know this is
fantastic but there's and it's a really
great to see everything kind of included
in you know dartium and the dart editor
itself it's it's very nice workflow you
don't have to jump to a lot of different
places everything's contained but
there's gonna be points in time when you
want to do things you know you want to
script them out you want to do them
faster you're not gonna do them you'll
manually you know buy control running
something and so that's what brings us
into the next topic which is headless
browser testing and this is really done
you know dart provides a very nice
utility to take care of this it's a it's
a headless browser with full dom like
brad said and it's faster than running
you know something like HTTP unit and
selenium so anything that we can do with
a browser we can do in the headless
browser so we use content shell which is
the tool itself and the way that we do
this is we call this with an argument of
dump render tree and you'll see that the
file that it's pointing to is actually
the same you know that we invoke that
you saw on the previous slide with
within the browser itself and when we
call that we see that same content to
you know all our tests past so we're
good to go but it's happening you know
on the command line so it can be done
much quicker and and built into our
build steps later on
would have been negative against like
let's say you had a faulty faulty
webpage
so so you mean in terms of like you want
to test like like errors like you expect
errors yeah so yeah I think do we have
an example of that I don't think we have
I don't think we have an example of it
but it's something that you you could do
it's just all depends on how you
structure your test so yeah we have the
things that there's there's more code
behind the scenes it's actually
something that we didn't prepare for
this particular application but we can
definitely add that into the github
projects and show it as an example
that's something that you'd like to see
yeah I'm sure there are plenty of
examples and maybe Seth can answer that
one when we're when we're done you can
talk to that cuz I know some of the dart
team there they're running hundreds of
these types of tests and analyzing out
to us so I'm sure they're doing those
types of tests but basically anything
you can do from a dart unit test you
you're running in the head in headless
mode so if you're familiar with like a
phantom Jas or something like that it's
it's that for Dart
maybe a little more primitive but
hopefully it'll evolve over time so now
I want to talk you know the server piece
you know Seth mentioned dart has HTTP
TCP all this stuff built in of course we
talk about the low-level handlers the
request handlers and stuff but I don't
program like that you know I that
reminds me of like 1999 java servlets I
typically like to use a web framework it
makes me more productive I don't have to
handle you know parsing URL paths and
stuff like that and so we're just gonna
jump straight to it this is a framework
it's called start Dart it rhymes if
you're familiar with Express for node if
you're familiar with Sinatra for Ruby
rat-pack for groovy I think something
sparked for Java
there's tons of frameworks like this
that make it really easy to deal with
with URL routing and stuff like that and
so what we're doing here is we're
invoking start what you see is this this
public web that is we're pointing it to
the server where we're serving our
static content out of our CSS files our
dart script
and then this is where we're declaring
that we want to handle this route so the
code whether you have the dot dot dot
that will get invoked any time we do a
post to that route which is of course
important because we're gonna be posting
a URL to this route in order to get back
a hash and so let's kind of quickly look
at what we would fill this with should
be pretty straightforward we're getting
the URL from from the request we're
hashing it using a simple shop hatch
right built into the dart library
awesome dart has a standard library has
all this great stuff in it
so I didn't have to write a shot house
hashing algorithm or anything like that
I was able to just take it right out of
the library and then we're using a Redis
client obviously I don't show how you
started it up here I didn't that was
necessary but we're doing something
simple we're setting the hash is the key
the URL is the value and of course this
is asynchronous and so I Seth mentioned
this is where futures come into play and
so we're saying when this is done we're
gonna invoke this function here and
we're gonna say respond with the hash
and so I mean stuff kind of touched on
it but it's kind of nice to be able to
use this future syntax especially when
you get multiple of these vens you avoid
that callback health so we really like
that as we were programming and actually
this is a simplified version we have
like an over engineered like hashing one
that uses much more than the actual
github repo and then this is just you
know so we've persisted it to torretta
so we persisted the hash and now we need
the redirect function so when someone
visits the shortened URL we're gonna
look it up just simply with Redis get
we're gonna get the hash again this is
asynchronous so we're using a future
we're getting the value and we're
redirecting so again very very simple
readable code in Dart we love it
all right so so just like we tested the
client we're gonna test the server as
well and what's great about running the
same code on the server and the client
is that things are gonna feel very
familiar so like we did before we're
gonna pull in the unit test library and
we're gonna do something a little bit
different because we're not going to be
testing you know the HTML we're actually
going to use the virtual machine in this
instance and to test that the you know
the hash is working properly we first
check to see that it's just returning
something we just want to make sure that
it's not null and then we know what the
specific hash will be it's a simple hash
so we're gonna test for that specific
hash and to run it all you do is in the
command line dart whatever you're you
know test files name is and you can see
you know whether it passes or fails and
in this case you know it passes all
right so set touch on this so we won't
really we don't have a lot to say about
it because it's so simple deployment
Roku it's great option this is literally
what it took for us to get this running
on Heroku Heroku create Seth mentioned
the second command we give it a URL to
what they call a build pack which is
essentially instructions to create a
virtual machine on the fly very simple
Heroku add-ons we add a Redis datastore
and you know within seconds we had a red
ass database and then we just get push
and so it's a great way if you're just
getting started with dart and you're
building a cool app and you want to show
it to people definitely try out Heroku
and if you google the dart build pack
there's instructions for a little more
in-depth for getting us all working
all right so just a question to
everybody
does anybody know about how many you
know browser and OS combinations there
are out there a million that's that's I
think that's pretty close but another
guess here let's go with let's go with
many many well as many permutations as
possible so there what's that
includes different versions too yeah
what so so you see this is quickly you
know spiraling out of control there's at
least over 200 different combinations of
I'll say the modern one so not not every
single one I was just trying to get as
many you know numbers as I could but
yeah that's there there's some cutoff
date so but for the modern ones let's
say that it's it's over 200 about
approximately the different combinations
and so when we're when we're creating
you know web applications are all of us
going out and testing all those
combinations you know ourselves manually
probably not so that brings us to our
next segment which is cross-browser
testing a selenium probably everybody's
pretty familiar with you know selenium
IDE you can record tests within your
browser selenium server you run those
tests we're actually you know darts got
capabilities where you can actually do
the scripting for the tests within dart
so again you're keeping all of your code
in in one place and using the same
language and here it's we just picked
that one sample but basically we're
creating the webdriver here in selenium
and we're saying I want to test on an
Android Browser picture multiple
iterations of this you know you've got
Firefox Chrome etc everything that you
could that you could stuff in you know
add as many as you need to
and then the actual so that's that's
setting up the actual test itself is you
know what we're doing is we're basically
you know finding again you know we're
finding an element we're doing something
to that element and what's what's neat
is we're actually back to the future'
syntax that we saw earlier
so again if this is a simplified version
but we're basically nesting you know
we're able to stagger a whole lot of
asynchronous calls to actually achieve
the the testing that we want and right
in the middle of everything it smack dab
in the middle of everything we can
actually you know throw in an
expectation so that's that's your test
right there so you you can you can have
multiple ones of these chained off of
each other and it's just it's just a
nice way to actually you know again
format that's put it in a very readable
format and and execute a lot of
different different tests in a lot of
different expectations so yes selenium
directly in dart is awesome so and you
know as Matt mentioned there's 200 plus
combinations and maybe some of you guys
have seen this it's called sauce labs I
think is actually buy a bunch X Google
guys that ran their their internal
testing but it's a web service that
works with selenium that lets you test
like tons of different permutations so
once you have the selenium code working
locally you just point it directly at
the sauce lab servers and in parallel
they're gonna test against a bunch of
different browsers and so we actually
took the tests no no I have it here and
we ran it against Firefox and what's
pretty cool is when you're running it in
sauce labs they actually will record
your in your entire set run your tests
show you the output any types of error
messages and it's really a boring video
it's just showing what we showed you
like two times already but you can see
it's running it's running with the dart
library and it's running on the sauce
labs
you know engine and so this is something
that you can start using today to test
in all these different permutations and
scenarios the other thing I wanted to
show just because it was so easy I
decided I wanted to test our app in
Android right why not I just had to
change like literally one one parameter
and in sauce um I'm testing it in
Android and this actually ended up being
pretty fascinating and it kind of goes
to Seth's earlier point is that we
should be testing everything on mobile
and using the viewport and I think this
will become very clear when I show you
what we found when we ran this on
Android so we're running on Android and
I'm not going to show the video I'll
just show some of the screenshots we
instruct selenium to click on the field
and add the text and what does it
immediately do it zooms in all big and I
can't see any of the page now I can't
even see the button and selenium is able
to actually put in the the URL so that
was scripted correctly but then we tell
selenium to click the button and
selenium fails selenium says we can't
fix it to let me read this though this
web element is not visible and may not
be clicked and so that's actually kind
of awesome because when I normally want
to using a tool like selenium I'm
thinking it's gonna find bugs like
glitches in code but this actually kind
of felt like a UX error
so again just kind of a nice byproduct
of this is being able to test on mobile
see how your app looks so maybe you have
Android but you don't have iPhone or you
have iPhone but you don't have an iPad
this does all these permutations it's
free for open-source projects and there
are paid plans and it's probably cheaper
than hosting all the infrastructure
yourself so definitely highly recommend
it I don't think we have a question oh
yes
with sauce labs I saw I was testing
localhost yes so with the way scythe
Labs works is it actually is like a
bundled version of selenium that proxies
so what happens is you're actually
almost exactly like what you are showing
with the dev tools I'm running the app
locally and sauce labs is providing a
local server that's proxying all the
traffic to their servers in their
environments so I'm very similar to what
you demo was there another question
okay we're jumping back into the pitch
so the kind of last technology we wanted
to touch on was continuous integration
obviously we've built our app we're
running our tests be great to do that
automatically especially in a team
setting you know if we have multiple
collaborators etc and so back in October
of 2011 when dart launched my company
drone i/o started supporting dart as a
language for continuous integration and
so a lot of the dart projects are doing
continuous integration on drone i/o it
supports other languages as well so
that's what I wanted to show to you
today we're gonna go ahead and click on
no maybe not so I actually have it up
right here so this is drawing i/o and
yeah alright I'm showing up it's
continuous integration server if you're
familiar with Jenkins similar type of
concept
some interesting things with drone i/o
it's completely hosted like sauce labs
you don't have to set it up yourself you
don't have to manage your own servers
you can just login to the website and
set up an account but that's actually
not what I'm showing you today I'm
actually showing you the open-source
version of drone i/o so this is actually
something you'll be able to download and
run on your own servers you know if
you're running Jenkins today this this
would be an alternate solution so we
actually haven't showed this yet and
it's not scheduled to come out next week
but I was really excited to show it and
I've been like waiting to show this to
people so
bear with me because it's not quite
production ready yet so fingers crossed
to the the demo gods that Seth was
praying to earlier so we're gonna go in
and we're gonna set up our repository
from github so I'm just gonna go ahead
and type that in I think that's what it
was called alright so just that simple
we added the project it actually linked
it to github it added a key it set up
hooks that will automatically trigger a
build every time developer pushes a code
change so very simple to get up and
running with with CI especially if
you're kind of used to downloading
installing Jenkins installing software
all that kind of stuff but so let me
just kind of jump back into the the
pitch because I think the one thing we
want to show is how do we set up a build
is how do we instructed our build
commands how do we tell it to compile or
run our run our dart code run our dart
tests and we do that with a simple yamo
configuration file that you'll check
into the root of your repository and
this has some benefits in the sense that
you can build branches differently but
so what does this llam file do it sits
in the root of your posit or the first
thing we're saying is the image we want
to use a dart image the cool thing about
drone is it runs all your builds inside
a virtual machine and it downloads those
virtual machines from a centralized
repository using a technology called
docker so you actually don't ever have
to install your own software or
configure your own build environments we
have pre-built virtual machines so dart
Java for the Java developers out there I
think 14 different languages and
multiple versions the second pieces
we're just instructing it what are the
build commands we want it to run and
then we could optionally even deploy to
Heroku at the end of the build
automatically to get that continuous
delivery flow going and so let's see how
do we want to do this just to jump back
in and show you how this would work this
is my github repository and we're gonna
make a change to this file to just
trigger a build in real time it should
email me that's my email address so feel
free to send me a note if you ever want
to
and we're gonna make the change and
we're notified if you a WebSocket
new-build running go ahead and click
that and then we can actually see the
build output streaming live in real time
so it's gonna run our build test so this
is a technology that is available today
on line 4 if you're developing open
source projects open source start feel
free to use this to automate your unit
test to automate your deployments and if
you're interested when we have this
available next week definitely check it
out is the open source project I'm just
a comment on the on the benefit of you
know continuous integration is really
great to have a tool like drone where
you don't have to think about running
things all the time you know it it
essentially you just want to be you know
as lazy as possible you don't want to
worry about having to run your any any
tests you don't have to worry about
certain checks you want as a developer
you want to do cool stuff you don't want
to be bogged down in the boilerplate and
getting on board with you know automated
testing automated builds automated
deployment is really really going to
help you out and you can just you know
discover new things which is what we
what we like to do so
so just to recap you know what have we
learned today we we built an entire dart
application so client and server we saw
that this that you know the same codes
used on both client and server we
persisted something to a database so we
went round trip we tested things with
various testing tools we saw you know
whether it's through HTML or the command
line and we actually deployed it so we
deployed something and it was live it's
out in the world there and as we were
doing so we touched on a few of the
language features you know of dart and
you know cement some additional tools
that can help you with the workflow
again wrapping up with that continuous
integration and really showing how you
know that could really ease your
workflow as a developer
so you know I think in conclusion right
dart is awesome dart has an awesome
ecosystem and it's still a very young
language and you know hopefully some of
these tools you know if you're coming
from a different background job or
whatever you'll you'll feel a little
more at home and you'll they'll help you
be a little more productive so what
should you do
try dart test things use tools and
deploy so thank you everyone and we'd
love to take some questions
yep yep yes so yeah so the the website
drone dot IO that is live it's been live
for a year and it's like think of it as
like a hosted Jenkins for for anyone to
use but what I demoed is the open source
edition that you can download install
and run directly on your own servers and
you should see that like literally
anytime in the next couple days I was
hoping to be ready for today but you
know how things go so and it's harder to
people that want to use Jenkins maybe
you you want to do CI what you wanted on
your own servers it's called drone drone
dot IO is the website and so yes
sometime next week so we'll be
announcing it so we usually announce
that stuff on Twitter or whatever so if
it's something you're interested in find
us on Twitter and we'll as we're making
announcements and we're also actually
giving a talk related to it
Dart plus docker virtualization and
drone on Thursday at Rackspace in
downtown San Francisco so if you're in
that area she definitely come to that
talk as well I think Seth will be there
but not speaking but you can probably
ask him questions that you didn't get to
ask here there
if you want nope no pressures yeah any
any other questions yes
I mean I think that that's probably a
question for Seth's
expertise I'm gonna say dart is osman
has no memory issues but I'm gonna let
Seth reinforce that fact yeah no we
don't have memory leaks so I was easy to
answer no I won one distinction of
course I don't know what libraries using
etc but one thing that we take very
seriously on the dart project is tool
ability and so we've been working on
this project called Observatory which is
actually a polymer app you connect
directly to the virtual machine and you
get to inspect it in real time and we're
adding more and more things to it things
like what are my eye slits doing right
now
what's a heat profile going on right now
what's a CPU profile going on right now
so you know I don't I don't know and
every time people have bugs but we hope
to give you the tools that go in and
find the problem and fix the problem any
other questions or any others for set
before you sits back down
thank you again all right thanks
everyone